den vorschlag habe hier deswegen geht
noch mal drauf und alles klar auf dieser
seite gibt es tatsächlich ein video in
dem der name escape vorkommt und von
herzen kommen zu einem neuen video ich
habe vor kurzem ihr ein video von luca
reingeschaut ok und in diesem video ging
es darum dass luca auf einer pornoseite
wo ich muss sagen dass zu sehen hat mich
persönlich schon ein bisschen
erschüttert okay die privatsphäre von
youtube an heutzutage wird schon soweit
verletzt dass man ihre gesichter auf
pornoseiten publik und deine irgendwie
drunter schreibt boyle faktor music
industrie oder sowie so oder so hat mir
lukas video link dazu ist eine
beschreibung die augen dafür geöffnet
das problem gibt wir haben in
deutschland ein problem damit dass
youtube auf pornoseiten hochgeladen
werden es kann so nicht sein da war ich
brauche zeit einem video sagen oder wird
man sowieso direkt ist und der ganze
kanal geht an operation kleiner brühl
und was kann gegen dieses problem machen
leute der erste schritt auf dem weg zur
lösung ist sich zu informieren und
deswegen werden leute wie einige seiten
wie stöbern ja keine sorge wir alles
denn wie ein youtube ok wird es freut
mich meinen kanal und wir gucken einfach
was man so auf diversen seiten zum
schlagwort sg findet okay alles leute
hier die erste seite wird die barbie in
faery topia community wiki bestimmt er
kennt keiner von euch irgendwie das
farbschema der seite wieder mit der sge
das zeigen die ergebnisse für relevant
ist das video in der wilferdinger suchen
wir wollen nach den vorschlag haben wir
das ding raus und alles klar auf dieser
seite
die wies nummer rabbis fan community
gibt es tatsächlich ein video in dem der
name sg vorkommt und ford escape 44
sekunden 2020
[Musik]
okay das ganze video besteht daraus dass
ein typ mit dem handy am ohr in die
kamera schaut der show aufgetreten die
kamera so dass ganze musikvideo mann im
hintergrund läuft deckung hate erste
frage warum macht man so musikvideo ist
okay kann man sagen kunst verhaltener
alles da leute zweite frage warum lädt
man ein musikvideo auf einer plattform
für pornografie hoch kann mir das
irgendwann beantwortet ich verstehe den
ganzen winter hinter nicht wieso lädt
man ein musikvideo auf seiner seite
rotes machen können sind menschenrechte
gebe auf die nächste seite was haben wir
hier rast ist glaube ich gutefrage.net
wenn nicht alles täuscht ja doch ja ja
ja das ist passt auch von den farben
perfekt auf infrage wie roman was kommt
dabei raus nein ich will nicht gab es
gibt irgendeine rolle die ihm wie er
heißt kann ich irgendwie einfach nur als
kennerin steht was ist so einem scheiß
seite alter babys verrät ob jahrzehnten
community 'wer viel geiler als ok wenn
er nicht vielleicht spsg zockt sorry we
can find you looking for common als ob
da alles klar die seite hat auf jeden
fall schon mal ordentlich verkauft so
dass man gar nichts die seite gibt die
frage punkt net ist auf jeden fall nicht
geeignet für so ein unterfangen leute
schauen wir weiter
käse langsam was ich ja auch nicht mit
wo wir noch gucken kann echt alles klar
auf diese seite hier
das müsste dann glaube ich youtube sein
wir müssen mal oben ein
drei ergebnisse für drei ergebnisse zu
fk okay aber diese drei ergebnisse ob
gott alter was ist das okay heute das
fünfte werden sabotiert werden für eine
person name fiel einfach krass
sabotierten unserer recherche und andere
seiten
wir haben den auftrag nachzuforschen wir
können jetzt nicht auch wenn er
weitermacht okay was habe ich hier
laut.de
das ist ein interview das steht ja ich
mache den scheiß in erster linie nur für
mich mein team ist nicht primär dass man
mich bundesweit kennt was haben wir hier
unten sk jan tags wie die lenort hypes
auf jahren was zur hölle ist jahren
faden garn die dielen mit garn löwe was
gibt's jedoch für seiten alter dem
community es ja ich habe eigentlich kein
steam singleplayer manchmal wirklich
leute im ernst wer mit so vielen seiten
bis kostet die sind die frage von matt
durchgegangen wir sind durch youtube
durch die angewandte auf steam und wir
haben die quellen immer nicht gefunden
das kann einerseits bedeuten dass es
nichts gibt oder versteckt
das was von diesem kleinen video ich
musste auch mal ein bisschen
nachforschen und einfach selbst ein
gutes gefühl bei dieser ganzen sache
endlich gefallen hat dann könnt ihr hier
oben zufällig seite dürfen wir abdecken
hier und den kanal bringen hier oben das
ist absolute spezialangebot pizza xxl
für drei euro
die neueste folge was geht von meinem
format mit unitymedia checkte sarah und
la sexta und selbstständig wie immer
leute wir kennen uns so langsam wird es
zeit